well hello we are excited for our next
talk dev staging and production and data
engineering with terraform uh by sarah
krasnick and we're excited to have sarah
she's a data engineer at perpay and i'm
happy to hand it over to you great
thanks um really excited to talk about
basically how to support three
environments in data engineering enabled
by kind of infrastructure as code so
with that um let's dive in so
first a little background on me i lead
data engineering at perpay which is a
fintech company based in philadelphia in
the united states um so i'm based out of
uh there as well i um aside from kind of
data engineering i'm also an avid
tech blogger and just generally like to
kind of keep up with uh startups in the
data space and kind of see
where the data and analytics space is
kind of
evolving um
with that
i'll kind of start by diving into uh
what doesn't even why do people have
three uh environments being development
staging into production both in software
engineering um and then kind of how does
that translate to the analytics stack um
that'll kind of bring us to what testing
means in the analytics world and
specifically what testing data really
entails
and then lastly diving into kind of the
infrastructure side of things what is
terraform
how it enables kind of reliable scalable
and kind of test the platforms in the
data world
so many of you are likely familiar with
kind of continuous integration tools
like github that really enable
collaboration and kind of a group of
people to
work on a single code base
so different branches kind of correspond
to
different levels of development
testing and accuracy so to kind of break
that down
we have let's start with the master
branch or the main branch or you know
whatever your default on this call this
is the branch that of of code that is
the highest level of testing it's gone
to the highest level of testing it's the
most reliable the most accurate this is
your production code this is kind of
downstream dependencies and that's what
makes a production
so
with uh then we go to maybe a
development branch or a staging branch
and sometimes this could kind of be
conflated with the future branch as well
but we have this kind of a release
candidate and
this is where you might put up a pull
request or kind of uh
understand what is different between
development master to
develop a new feature and what you do
here when you want to basically merge
new things into production is you you go
and test it
but before you even do that right you
have
feature branches and these are uh
development branches so
software engineers data engineers anyone
kind of interacting with github and with
the code they can make change changes
and submit them for review and here you
see that right we can have multiple
people uh working on different features
at the same time
and uh when you submit a pull request
that feature will be merged into kind of
your your staging branch
so in kind of in software engineering
this is a lot
better defined but in let's talk about
data engineering so
the separation between these uh branches
gets
trickier because the the environment in
data engineering it's not just code
there's data involved right so
in production you're running
a lot of maybe sql transformations that
connect to a data warehouse and that in
this data warehouse you're also you're
storing kind of third-party data whether
that's accounting data marketing data
any sort of third-party tool or even
internally into from the organization
maybe uh data from a kind of a core
production database that's being put in
a warehouse to kind of house it in one
place um
on top of all of that the code is
running sql transformations and writing
back to uh
to schemas or having views um that are
considered kind of the the source of
truth for metrics and in the organism in
the organization
so
with that said um kind of what might
differentiate production um in this
environment well
production as i mentioned before has
downstream dependencies so
in software you have right an
application production it's deployed to
your end users to the consumers
of your of your product um but in
internal analytics your users are your
stakeholders so product managers
marketing leads uh you know really
anyone that's looking at the output that
might be you know for example um put
inside of a dashboard they look at these
dashboards and look at these metrics to
make decisions so for example
in the product manager's case
we um let's say there's kind of a new
product launch or a new feature launch
they might look at a dashboard to
understand how the feature is performing
or maybe it's an a b test to understand
whether we should
kind of roll back the ad test or maybe
roll it out to a larger population
but
the the purpose of the staging branch
and environment is to to test code to
ensure it's ready for production right
because we mentioned that production is
kind of your most tested but in
analytics it's not just testing code
it's also testing
data you want to ensure that your
outputs are comparable and the most
thorough way to do that is to read
production data so that the changes um
between a staging
environment and a production environment
is just the code that's being run it's
specifically the transformation not the
changes in the environment right so it's
you're not um you want to compare the
apples to apples and you want to ensure
that any differences that you see
you can be 100 sure that there are
differences in the code that you made as
opposed to you know potentially just
being a difference in environments and
you don't know which is which but one is
a problem
that won't be fixed in production
because that's that that being the code
and then the other would not persist in
production so
you don't want to kind of accidentally
assume those things but
in staging right where do you write to
you're not going to overwrite production
data that like doesn't make any sense
you're testing these things you want to
test them in an environment that doesn't
actually affect production and more than
that things get you know
the stakes get so much higher when it's
not just dashboards if you're
operationalizing analytics meaning
you're sending data from your data
warehouse to third-party tools via
reverse ctl
with tools like census and high-touch
kind of there are there's so many things
at plate here because you're sending
data that
is way more likely to be exposed to your
uh end user it's not just internal it
could be right into a marketing tool
that sends emails or into a sales tool
that sends emails or into shopify that
is data that is exposed in your
storefront so you really want to make
sure right before pushing into
production that your data is formatted
in a way that kind of complies with your
reverse ctl integrations
again testing is the most important
right it has here it it it has the
highest impact on stakeholders and and
customers especially in a b2c product
so testing data right let's jump again
right we're making these parallels
between software engineering and data
engineering so in the software
engineering world um we have pi test
it's in python an agreed upon framework
for for unit testing um but
in the data world that's just
it gets you part of the way there but
it's just not enough because you could
unit test code that you think you
accounted for in all cases but the the
data is telling you otherwise right you
want to make sure that
um
you want to make sure that you're not
dependent on right changes upstream and
data continuously changes right it
updates new things happen time goes by
and you want to ensure that nothing
changed upstream that would
flow through
downstream um and
come off as as bugs so
um kind of abe gong of superconductive
has really talked a lot about like
pipeline tests so making your
dependencies run only if tests pass as
specifically as part of your data
pipeline so let's say you have
raw data you're piping into your data
warehouse you run a transfer you run one
transformation then you run another
transformation and then you have these
downstream dependencies that
um that feed dashboards
well if you run pipeline tests that
means before your data gets to a place
where your dashboards kind of pull from
you run data data quality tests and
ensure that kind of what you
expect is you validate what you expect
is actually what's happening and if that
fails you just don't push data
through to dashboard so your data's
stale but it's
um but it's not inaccurate or it's not
buggy so i won't kind of go into this
too too much but this here is really
specific to kind of testing your inputs
and outputs um
and then your unit testing right it's
testing code and business logic but here
testing data just adds a whole other
layer of quality
there are kind of plenty of tools out
there i mean i just mentioned great
expectations there's kind of soda data
fold i mean plenty of tools only some of
which i even you know listed here but um
there's so many frameworks for
observability quality and
they are fundamentally different from
software testing because they test data
so
i'd argue that
to do so effectively you need a
production-like environment so that you
can ensure that you're replicating data
and you're not making assumptions about
what that underlying data looks like
so
how exactly does that fit into kind of
these these branches that i talked about
earlier kind of in code
so
you
that means entirely
storing your data entirely separately in
a
in in in a different warehouse or a
different database within the same
warehouse but the point is that you want
to have this separation between uh
production and staging
and
with
production right third party data you
want it to
write to both of these places so that
you can replicate production in a
staging environment that doesn't have
downstream dependencies where business
decisions aren't being made on top of
that data
you want to be able to replicate it as
close as possible
so again this kind of i talks about like
an apple's apple's comparison but it
really um kind of that's what it boils
down to
i mean if you think about right
like science experiments and biology
chemistry really any kind of
experimental
field
you want to kind of limit the number of
variables that you're testing unless
you're testing interaction between two
things maybe um but
uh
it's kind of the same
take that same principle and add it here
that the only thing that you change you
want to try to change one thing at a
time right so if you change the the code
and you're trying to test maybe your
your future branch a right you're trying
to test a feature branch or test a
staging environment as it compares to
production
it's a lot easier if only one thing is
changing being the code as opposed to
having to think about well
is it just my staging data set that's
that's maybe not encompassing of all
these different use cases
is it lagging is there something else
going on
it kind of takes that out of the
equation um completely
so
we talked about staging right um so
having like a completely functionally
separate data source that kind of mocks
that mimics uh production as close as
possible but
speaking to kind of feature branches
similarly each person could um you know
read from the production warehouse and
kind of have their own
development schema to play around in so
that again we're not writing to
production and uh hopefully that is kind
of guarded by
um you know
permissions and um
the everything that is done by kind of
in a development environment in
exploration is just is just functionally
separate
so
right in both software and data
engineering like infrastructure matters
right we're keeping things functionally
functionally separate hopefully i've
kind of gotten that gotten that point
across and kind of convince you of the
importance of that but
how your warehouse is deployed right all
of the security around it you're your
testing frameworks your cloud
infrastructure for machine learning um
kind of everything that plays into that
it it matters and
what if kind of you need to make a
change um deploying a new machine
learning model and
let's say right there's a new model it's
much more computationally intensive it
has um uh it stresses your warehouse a
little bit more and you need to
understand right will it impact other
other queries what do you need to do
maybe it's more memory intensive kind of
there could be a whole host of things
but
the last thing that you want to do is
impact production workloads if the model
reads from the data warehouse that is
the production data warehouse so
testing this new code involves changing
and hopefully therefore testing
infrastructure
so if staging and production
infrastructure is functionally is is
separate then that involves right we can
test the infrastructure we can push the
bounds of staging seeing what what it
can handle and kind of being as most you
know being most efficient with our cost
to not over provision so we don't kind
of have to pay for those resources but
similarly
we can have all of that testing in in
staging uh as well
and again hopefully those environments
are as similar as can be from an
infrastructure uh standpoint as well
so
data platforms right have have grown in
complexity um they're kind of more
sophisticated than they were one two
five years ago um while being able to
provide kind of better tools
for for data quality um for your
stakeholders right the higher the
quality the more trust there is
in in data and the better decisions that
you're making because you're making them
on things that are actually um accurate
but
with this kind of complexity means
more more tools more moving parts and
i just mentioned right having like two
different um environments and kind of a
silo almost like partially a third
environment in terms of like some sort
of development that can be a lot a lot
to handle especially right highlighting
everything that's that's that could be
considered infrastructure like that that
you have to duplicate um
that's a lot
um
like functionally separate means
duplicated and uh before i kind of dive
into how to make this happen right i'd
like to make a comment here that's a lot
of the questions when i talk about
different environments especially from a
data world especially in the data world
um the question of like pricing comes up
and so uh yeah you you could
uh you could kind of close to double the
cost of your infrastructure um by kind
of setting up these two environments i
think that's that's kind of coming off
as what's going to happen here but
i would kind of uh anyone that's kind of
doubting the the need for that i would
uh compare that to the cost of making a
wrong decision that harms your business
or not being able to run certain tests
where you're pushing out information to
decision makers that make decisions on
products that impact your end customers
those the the cost and risk of that
i would argue is is much much greater
so
going back to kind of the the
infrastructure side of things um you
know you want to test um in staging as
well and test those test everything
downstream so that's why i kind of you
need this whole uh
line of all of this infrastructure so
how do you
how do you automate this and make it
repeatable right if i personally as a
data engineer like if i had to do
anything twice i'd uh
would much prefer instead of doing it
manually to try to code it so that it
can be done a third fourth fifth time if
needed
and this is where um kind of the i'll
introduce kind of the concept of
infrastructure as code so it's
exactly what it sounds like um you know
define your infrastructure in code
and that code can be versioned in github
just like your transformation code and
sql just like your python code and
this kind of allows for a few things um
the first is repeatability you can copy
your code you can deploy it to staging
and deploy to production um
and you can also destroy your
infrastructure and recreate it right and
i'd be remiss not to mention tristan
handy's talk who's the ceo of dbt labs a
few weeks ago at the future of data
conference about how
kind of infrastructure as code can truly
enable the the modern data experience
and
he mentioned something that's really
important kind of a a common theme in uh
devops which is treating your
infrastructure as cattle and not as pets
and what i mean by that is
uh you want to uh make it repeatable you
want to you don't want to be you know
your heart tied to a server that if
something goes wrong you're spending a
lot of time um you know trying to fix it
so on and so forth and instead right you
don't want to clog your production
environment with code or infrastructure
that belongs to feature branches that
production environment
could be looker right that just has
these dashboards that you thought you
might use someday but you're just afraid
to destroy um from the infrastructure
infrastructure side of things if things
are coded you can destroy them knowing
that if they're just if that code is
just stored in a branch you can very
easily recreate them if uh there is a
use for that down the line so
kind of thinking broadly here this
doesn't have to be just
kind of the common things that you think
of this infrastructure being like your
warehouse it could be what if it was all
your mappings from your warehouse to
your um kind of operational tooling in
the in the reverse ctl sas tool that you
use it could be dashboards kind of you
you name it so
how does
like terraform actually work so a lot of
software tools um
and cloud tools like you know aws gcp
azure kind of the big three are
supported so that could be um
databases virtual machines
security groups everything that you know
all of the security groups and like
roles and stuff that everyone always
struggles with that's all
supported as as declare it's very
declarative so declaring resources as
code now
setting this up um kind of on a on on
your computer you can run a terminal
command to launch all of this
infrastructure and
just as easily run a terminal command um
to
first code a change and then run a
command to apply the change or right if
you no longer need it destroy all that
infrastructure
being able to very quickly recreate it
again
so
kind of here in
right you could think okay well how does
this
kind of apply to uh the the data
workflow as opposed to the software
engineering workflow and i'd like to
point out kind of
imagine if there was right your entire
data platform
from raw data to etl to um warehouse to
transformation to metrics to reverse ctl
um and and beyond right what if you
could what if all of that and all of
that configuration could be set up as
code so
you could launch um dbt in the cloud as
well as your snowflake database and you
can code all your etl mappings in five
trans so that you can write this data to
a staging production without manually
redoing them and accidentally missing
something
now taking a step further let's talk
about bi
so
right
all your liquor sources look ml
dashboards like translate them to code
and you can kind of um uh launch
everything all at once and you can store
all the dependencies between the
different tools in your data platform as
well so something that kind of isn't
shown here are kind of third-party tools
that um
the third-party tools for you know like
reverse ctl processes for example um
airbite has already written about kind
of deploying etl and reverse ctl and
terraform um i believe inside a virtual
machine but i think that you know
the future
i believe is third-party tools
supporting these terraform providers so
that you can integrate your data
platform um as easily as possible
so where does that kind of get us it
gets us to a
data platform that is repeatable that is
testable um deleting dashboards doesn't
mean they're gone forever and they make
your data platform clean
and you can easily support multiple
environments to ensure the scale and
quality of your data products
so
i'll kind of leave you with with a few
things
between different environments in
testing right before production you
always want to be comparing apples to
apples to ensure you don't make
assumptions on accident um just like you
limit experiments to one variable limit
testing to just the code and not
environment environment differences or
just the infrastructure and not the code
now testing on full data sets ensure
ensures you also don't miss edge cases
that you may not have accounted for and
sort of like mock data that you might be
inclined to to have
setting up your environments as code
allows for these changes um to to be to
be repeatable and that you ensure that
your staging environment is as
production-like as you can get it and
lastly this all kind of really enables
better
testing coordination integration and
building trust in your data organization
um to help your whole business make kind
of data-driven decisions and kind of
operationalize as much
data as possible
and the last thing i want to mention is
just a shout out to
my co-worker and software engineer derek
who
has really
pioneered kind of terraform at
perpay and um you know there's been so
much collaboration between analytics and
engineering and uh hopefully that
inspires others to collaborate as well
and uh now it's time for questions so
thanks everyone
yes thank you so much uh we definitely
have a few minutes so we can answer some
questions uh which you can either put in
the q a function
or uh post them to chat
um i can looking at the chat from the
talk uh about you know 10 minutes ago
there's a question
about duplicating warehouses uh and the
cost of it um the question was like
whether
a full replica of the of the private
warehouse for staging would that double
the storage cost and is that just the
cost of business or
is there
something we could do about like
sampling or subsetting
yeah it's a great question i think that
you know i think partially it is the
cost of business but i think you can get
smart about it so for example um
if you are a business that is that is uh
10 years old i really doubt that it's um
worth uh having all 10 years of data
between production and staging it could
be enough just to have six months or one
year and if you're launching a new
product then um you know that's only
going to be forward-looking so sampling
and just making sure that
your tests are written in such a way
that
both in production and in staging you
can compare only the last year's uh
worth of data so that uh you really do
uh you know make it apples to apples
you're just kind of smart about not
duplicating so there's certainly things
there's certainly things that you can do
there the only other comment that i'll
make is
um
i think that uh you know having
infrastructure that is separate is
important so even if you have a
completely separate data warehouse or
database right i think that's really
important even if you don't duplicate um
all of history if you do have a long
history of your company
and then there i think there's a file
question to that similar like what about
the streaming data sources
yeah the streaming data is um i i think
that's that's really interesting um it's
definitely a lot harder to replicate but
um in that case um
i think a good
because that space is so new i think
it's kind of harder to um rather not new
but not as explored in kind of the
modern
data stack as people call it i think
there's kind of a lot to be figured out
in terms of how to to test streaming
data um
it might be a good i think that's a
great case where unit testing right
is really important in python and
mocking
because
it does change
between production and staging but what
i will say is trying to understand if
there are
staging or test environments upstream so
at least you can test your streams even
if they aren't exactly the same data as
production would be kind of my my first
approach
great uh one we had a question asking
what if your production data is
regulated the examples being hipaa or
customer ndas
yeah um so the approach that i've kind
of taken is all of the same regulations
that apply in production appliance
staging right all of the same
permissions if
someone doesn't have access to something
in production they shouldn't have access
to it in staging
and so i think all of that compliance
kind of still still holds but of course
i mean
per pay we're kind of in a uh in the
financial space there's obviously kind
of
regulations that that make it kind of
tricky and so uh definitely keeping that
in mind when replicating data and making
sure that all the security between
between warehouses when you take data
out of your um
you know out of your network that there
is all that same security in place so it
from that perspective it can also be an
overhead in terms of like maintaining
those two environments um but i do think
that um it has a lot of benefits as well
great uh next question would you
recommend using ansible or terra grunt
to facilitate terraform
um i have actually not used ansible
before and i'm only um i'm somewhat
familiar with terracott so don't know
that i can make a recommendation between
the two i don't have to do more research
but um i kind of use terraform as uh in
you know an example there's even other
tools like gloomy um which is like
python infrastructure is code so i i
think you know the the concept is is is
what matters
yeah we did have a comment that says
ansible and terraform work very well
together that's good feedback thank you
i think that's it thank you very much we
really appreciate the talk thank you so
much